[Musique]
moi je suis très très très contente
seent nous dire merci que ailleurs faut
toujours aller plus vite sans avir aucun
merci sans rien du tout que elle elle
nous dise merci tout le temps pour le
travail qu'on fait pour des sœurs je
pensais même pas qu'il faisait autant de
travail
c'est j'arrive toujours j'ai toujours du
mal à y croire d'ailleurs parce qu'il y
en a vraiment 80 quelques années ils
travaillent encore bien ils font tout je
suis porté et renouvelé à chaque fois
que je viens euh par la prière des sœurs
par les environs par la nature et en
fait quand j' REP par chez moi ben je
suis tout simplement
mieux je suis
reposée
alléluia à
lat
duur
alléluia
P glorifie ton
ch est la gloire en
ceond
T tour vers
nous fondé au 12e siècle l'abaye d' a
longtemps été un monastère d'homme ce
n'est qu'après la prère guerre mondiale
alors que les Allemands l'avaient
entièrement détruite que des femmes s'y
installèrent venu de l'abaye de la
coudre près de la Val comme leurs
prédécesseurs elles appartiennent à
l'ordre
cistercien pendant très longtemps comme
la plupart des monastères de l'ordre de
C in vécu de l'agriculture ce petit
verger représente à peu près tout ce
qu'il reste de cette époque là tu fais
très attention s parce que les grappes
sont fragiles tu pass sur le bois mais
pas sur les grappes ça y
est alors ici un tour là un tour et puis
tu me le
donnes bon alors tu es tu es à bonne
hauteur se balade pas trop attends lâche
lâche celui-là voilà
la Lexo divina une lecture approfondie
de la Bible est l'un des trois temps
forts de la journée monastique chez les
cisterciens elle se pratique au
scriptorium les deux autres temps forts
qui rythment la journée sont la prière
décomposé en six offices quotidiens
entre 4h du matin et 8h du soir et le
travail manuel le fameux or et labora de
saint
depuis les années 1950 c'est la
confiserie et la chocolaterie qui font
vivre les sœurs le monastère étant situé
à 30 km de reince elles inventèrent le
bouchon de champagne en chocolat fourré
à l'alcool un produit qui allait assurer
leur renommée dans la région voilà on
met un petit jet pour chemiser
ensuite on pose sur la tapoteuse pour
pouvoir crever les bulles
al voyez faut que ce soit pris sans plus
parce que sinon le bord est cassant si
c'est trop pris lorsqu'on a
rase en fait on fait ce qu'on nous
demande c'est
l'obéissance j'ai même dit à un
autre que je pourrais très bien êre
ailleurs qu m'enlever de la chocolaterie
ça ne me posera aucun problème çaer
d'autes
aussi mais le problème c'est il y a pas
de douseur pour
l'instant la relève alors cette crème
consiste en gantj et fondant et beaucoup
d'alcool alors on met moitié fondant
moitié GJ et ce GJ c'est du chocolat
auit praliné en fait qu'on achète et on
met 2 l de Mar à 60°
plus de la fine et un peu de
marusé nous mélangeons ça au
mélangeur et ensuite lorsquelle est bien
dure on remet un peu de chaude pour
pouvoir la travailler parce que on en
fait d'avance vous en mangé quelques
dans la journée quand même ah non non
non là là non al on est très
très sobre de ce
côtél
sub venir au besoins du monastère c'est
important parce que sinon comment vionss
nous on ne vit pas d'amour et de fraîche
quand
même je connaissais beaucoup de
communautés religieuses auparavant je
les ai visité toutes et puis il y en a
certaines communautés croyais que
j'allais rentrer chez
elle mais mon choix n'était pas fait
alors j'ai cheminé comme ça elles
espérait que exactement elles espéraent
très fort que j'allais rentrer dans une
ou l'autre
communauté et puis un jour j'ai appris à
connaître ini c'était pour moi
absolument inconnu j'ai connu une sœur
une religieuse d'une autre congrégation
qui pour elle ini c'était tout elle
connaissait ini alors vraiment ini
c'était le le paradis des déjà le
paradis les choses se sont précipitées
en fait j'étais toute jeune j'avais même
pas 20
ans et je suis allée en parler au prêtre
du village parce que je suis dans d'un
village et il m'a dit oh bah tiens
faudrait que tu lises ce livre là
c'était sur la trappe ah moi ça me
dépassait alors là pour moi lire ce
livre sur la trappe j'ai rien lu du tout
ça ne me tentait pas c'était des moines
qui
Tron qui creusent leur tombe un peu
chaque jour et cetera des des genres de
choses comme ça alors vraiment ça ne
m'attirait pas mais ce qui m'attirait
dans cette communauté c'était le silence
et la vie cachée vraiment la vie cachée
surtout je désirais vivre une vie euh
séparée du monde et c'est ce qui m'a le
plus attiré dans cette
communauté
le Seigneur a vraiment
ressuscité
REC pour nos
ur
le la nuit du temps se change en
lumiur
[Musique]
l' il est
vivant plus àre voi de celui qui nous
enne le Seigneur est vraiment
ressuscité
à la sortie de l'office de tierce les
cisterciennes se rendent au réfectoir
pour y déjeuner en
silence parfois le repas est accompagné
de musique ou bien d'une
[Musique]
lecture le silence reste une des
composantes fondamentales de la vie
monastique d'aujourd'hui qui n'a plus la
rigueur
[Musique]
d'autrefois
vers 14h30 les sœurs repartent dans
ateliers ou devant leurs ordinateurs
ell travaill l'équivalent d'un gros
mi-temps c'est un équilibre fragile sans
cesse remise en cause par les
difficultés économiques que connaissent
beaucoup de
[Applaudissements]
monastères
[Musique]
il y avait un monsieur qui était
mécanicien qui était venu pour nous
vendre un tracteur alors il était
accompagné par le fermier alors il
disait toujours au fermier mais
qu'est-ce qu'elle fout les bon sœur
derrière Cees murs alors un jour il lui
dit bah tu vas voir ce que
alors il l'a amené ici puis quand il a
vu qu'it sur le tracteur et qu'on avait
des machines et qu'on travaillait avec
des faux et tout ça alors il ne revenait
pas il dis c'est pas possible que des
sœurs fassent
ça on fait pas de la démolition on fait
aussi des on fait aussi des meubles on
fait des pu des racommodagees surtout la
semaine dernière nous avons détartré
tous les robinets de du monastère il
faut savoir tout faire alors oui et puis
et la semaine prochaine après on va
faire les nettoyer toutes les roulettes
des chariots graisser et nettoyer les
roulettes des
chariots
on est d'abord par
obéissance alors la grâce nous est donné
hein mais on est pas fait n'est pas fait
pour pour vendre par exemple j'avais
horreur de vendre de d'acheter de faire
le commerce vous mettez quelque chose en
dous quand il était beau il y a beaucoup
de monde mais aujourd'hui malgré le
mauvais temps il y a beaucoup de monde
oui parce qu'on apprécie beaucoup les
produits monastiques et nous bouchons
comme
VO beaucoup de succès ce sont les sur de
l'atelier qui ont fabriqué voyez quand
nous avons abandonné la fabrication de
fromage donc à la cade il y avait des
montants là où on posait les planches de
fromage alors ils sont démontés ils sont
assemblé ils ont mis des roulettes et
c'est sont arrangé comme ça et même la
table ceci fabriqué par les sœurs ceci
la même façon parce que ceci c'est de
chîn le bois de chî les parloires
d'autrefois avec leur grilles en fer
forgé ont laissé place à de petits
salons où chacun peut recevoir familles
ou amis bah oui moi aussi j'aime bien
toi tuas pas trop crevé non en pleine
forme en pleine forme ouais ça fait
combien de temps que tu étais pas venu
alors euh je crois presque 1 an et demi
oh ça passe vite je suis heureuse de de
voir qu'elle est heureuse j'ai besoin de
venir vérifier un peu qu'elle qu'elle
est heureuse et puis ça bon B là j'ai
pas de doute
là-dessus je suis très fière aussi moi
ça ça rejaillit aussi sur sur moi et
puis à ce qui se passe aussi dans sa
tête et puis dans son cœur quand elle
dit par exemple que que le manque
qu'elle
sentait maintenant est
comblé j'ai du mal à à le réaliser quoi
puis je pense que c'est des chose qu'on
doit même pas pouvoir mettre en mot ça
c'est c'est plus du domaine
du du ressenti il y a beaucoup de choses
que je que je faisais avec avec joie et
bon auquel j'étais attaché bon par
exemple je je lisais
énormément beaucoup beaucoup de livres
je passais presque toutes mes des fois
j'avallais un livre dans la journée ou
des fois davantage quand je faisais rien
d'autre bon ben ça me manque absolument
pas de et pourtant qu'est-ce que j'en ai
lu et qu'est-ce que j'aimais ça et une
fois une amie m'en a apporté un qui se
passait dans un dans un monastère pour
que je sois sûr que ça me
plaise mais je l'ai même ça ça me dit
plus rien maintenant si un livre me
parle pas du Christ ça ça ça me donne
pas enfin j'ai pas envie quoi bon j'ai
plus j'ai plus l'esprit à ça du tout il
y a vraiment quelque chose
qui c'est pas ma volonté en fait c'est
pas moi qui décide de ne plus
lire ce type de livre là mais mon goût
ne m'y porte plus quoi et c'est là qu'on
voit qu'il y a vraiment une uvre de
conversion qui se fait en
nous j'ai commencé la relure quand
j'étais postulante donc début 48 j'ai
commencé et c'estz curieux mais j'y suis
restée en général on vous changeit tout
le
temps à 28 ans j'ai été choisi comme
parmi les fondatrices de la clarté die
en Afrique alors m'a dit ben c'est très
bien là vous
allez faire un atelier de relure
complet alors
complé alors j'ai j'ai fait la l'atelier
le relir à donc que cétait à à Bou près
de Bou àou et j travaillé tout en
faisant autre chose pendant 35
ans j'ai grandi en Afrique au contact
des mes chures
africaines
alors elles m'ont appris beaucoup on
apprend beaucoup en Afrique on apprend à
apprendre on apprend à ne pas savoir on
apprend à savoir
que la France n'est pas tout l'Europe
n'est partout autres façons de faire on
apprend un autre tempérament on apprend
à prendre patience par l'impatience
comme disait une sœur
blanche
s que ça
bouge
pour la détente c'est excellent
excellent de quitter la
rive et de pouvoir y
revenir on revient à
neu ça fait 22 ans
maintenant chaque étape à sa couleur
l'étape d'une viciare à sa
couleur et puis oui petit à petit
quelque chose se stabilise accepte de se
laisser
porter de se laisser dériver un petit
peu ça vaut la peine puis ça vaut toutes
les
peines je n'ai pas l'impression d'avoir
renoncé ni à ma vie affective ni à ma
fécondité j'ai choisi de la vivre
autrement c'est
tout au contraire je crois que la vie
affective
il est possible de la vivre très
intensément autrement mais tout aussi
intensément et la fécondité pareil ce
n'est pas une vie désincarnée et la
vie proprement sexuelle n'est pas la
seule à à combler cette part de nousmême
qui est
sexuel
obéir comme un cadavre peut paraître
rigide pourtant non l'obéissance
ignatienne n'est pas du caporalisme où
les supérieurs commande en
Seigneur cette obéissance est absolue ne
signifie pas que
l'autorité ne signifie pas une autorité
absolue ah ça c'est bien la différence
entre obéissance absolue et autorité
absolue je viens de l'abaye Notre Dame
de la clarté Dieu au Congo il y a 2 ans
ma supérieure avait décidé que je vienne
ici pour faire la
théologie je suis aidée par ma mère sœur
Marie je trouve que son aide est très
très important parce que elle fait ce
que une mère fait à son enfant elle
m'apprend à marcher donc comment
travailler et ça me fait le cœur de voir
que ici bon des communautés tu vois tu
arrives dans un monastre ça fait à peu
près maintenant comme un musée il n'a
plus même des personnes une présence
religieuse pendant que nous nous
manquons où loger les jeunes hein c'est
ça fait mal mais voilà on ne peut pas
transporter des bâtiments en
Afrique c'est
ça faut pas oublier de boire un petit
peu hein oui si si faudrait mieux boire
h
faut pas boire trop
peu tout le me la moyenne d'âge à est de
75 ans plus de 20 sœurs sont octogénères
pour pouvoir les garder à l'abaye les
sœurs ont demandé et obtenu du
département le statut d'unité de vie
cela coûte moins cher à la collectivité
que des places en maison de retraite et
ça permet aux anciennes de terminer leur
vie entouré de l'affection des leurs et
soigné par du personnel compétent mais
ici comme ailleurs le manque de
nouvelles vocation se fait cruellement
sentir
on a beaucoup parlé sur la durée
d'engagement et cetera quoi et il disait
que beaucoup de prêtres partaient parce
que bon ben ils avaient vu ce que
c'était le ministère c'était bien mais
sans plus donc bon voilà on avait faiti
ça m'avait un
peué même au niveau de notre Ordre tu
sais quand on voit le nombre de départ
de jeunes moine ou Monial et maintenant
aussi beaucoup de jeunes Monial c'est
vrai que c'est très interpelant et les
AB abiss nous nous interrogeons
beaucoup c'est j'ai plus les CHR c'est
un signe des temps qui est qui est très
interpellant et qui qui fait chocf qui
beaucoup parler de ce que c'était pour
un jeune maintenant de s'engager et la
durée dans l'engagement quoi tout monde
cherche comment faire pour qu'
aujourd'hui nous nous vivions chaque
communauté selon sa son histoire sa
grâce du moment son âge et
cetera
par sa mort il a vaincu la mort à ceux
qui sont dans les temp
[Musique]
il conseiller et soutenu par des membres
de l'Ordre qui viennent les visiter
régulièrement les sœurs ont décidé
d'organiser des repas de groupe
réunissant une même classe d'âge ici ce
sont les jeunes il s'agit de se préparer
à entourer et épauler le mieux possible
les éventuelles jeunes antes que tout
appelle de leur
dans une araignée d' mon
verement c'est pas un
autre
viv il est à l'envers le
oui écoute je t'assure je te l'ai pas
mis la toute première abaye va se fonder
en
1128 plutôt sur ma gauche vous avez
quelques ruines là-bas
du tout premier monastère la vie va se
développer très très vite très fortement
très bellement tout au long du moyen-âge
et puis bien comme la communauté
s'enrichit et que la richesse et les
vertus ne vont pas longtemps ensemble
dit un texte il a l'inévitable période
de décadence jusqu'à la Révolution
française où le monastère est vendu
comme bien national c'est le cardinal
l'ingénieux qui va racheter la maison et
faire revivre cette maison donc au début
du 19e siècle ce lieu ici est
particulièrement connu à cause de l'ISSM
qui s'est converti à en
1895 donc wism un des amis de
Zola qui sent tout d'un coup se monter
en lui cette recherche et un de ses amis
va dire de lui c'est maintenant soit la
croix soit le suicide et donc HM vient
ici rencontre le père abbé de
l'époque il y a une confession et puis à
la grâce de Dieu et peut-être la grâce
du lieu qui fait que le cœur peut se
retourner le monastère va rester debout
donc jusque à la Première Guerre
mondiale ou à la fin en 18
le monastère est
rasé et le monastère actuel que vous
voyez là est reconstruit en
1929 et cette fois ce sont des sœurs qui
sont appelées à venir vivre à ini et
donc c'était le 29 novembre nous sommes
à 75 ans de de cette refondation
d' l'avenir est à Dieu disait Victor
Hugo
et je pense que c'est toujours
vrai nous essayons de
vivre nous nous devons vivre jusqu'au
bout ce que nous avons choisi de vivre
en réponse à l'appel du Seigneur après
c'est l'affaire du Seigneur si le
Seigneur veut qu'il y vive il saura en
prendre les moyens et s'il trouve qu'il
y a fait son temps et bien il n'y
acceptera de mourir comme dans une vie
humaine on vit et on Meur je pense que
la vie contemplative c'est un peu comme
les nappes fréatiques de l'église les
nappes fréatiques on les voit pas
et on les ignore même et puis tout à
coup on nous dit les créatiques sont en
baisse et c'est pour cela que il y a la
sécheresse qu'il y a ceci qu'il y a cela
si les NA tréatiques diminuent de façon
trop grosse trop importante c'est
dangereux pour
[Musique]
l'Église